Is there something safer than baby aspirin to take?
So, if you're, as a water why you're taking this,
do you test for this with a cheek swab?
I can, if you ask specifically for it,
if you're asking something to help prevent blood clots.
So, can there are, I know there's alternative perspectives
on using aspirin and using baby aspirin,
which is I think 88 milligrams of acetylcellic acid
to help with clotting.
I don't think even from an alternative perspective,
I know there's, you know, some studies that have come out
that it can damage your heart, it can damage the blood vessels
on a long-term basis what they used to.
I think they still may recommend taking a baby aspirin,
you know, every single day for people over a certain age.
I don't know if that is even, you know, recommendation anymore.
I do think that with some people,
yes, it did cause cardiovascular damage,
taking it on a long-term basis.
But taking it for a shorter basis because there's a potential
clot formation, I don't see anything wrong with that.
Is there other things that you could do to help prevent clot formation?
Yes, things garlic is probably your number one thing
to, as a blood thinner from a nutritional perspective.
And then using lumbarochitis and nanochitis,
those are two enzymes that could be very beneficial.
Those are in both the product called clear toxin,
the product called clear circulation.
Clear circulation has more things for blood vessels in it.
But the clear toxin has more things to help detox.
It can be really put together to help detox the ill effects
of the COVID vaccine or DNA vaccines.
But clear circulation might be another thing to think about too.
And like I said, garlic.